ecco eccomi eccomi qua buonasera a tutti
buon pomeriggio sono riccardo schirinzi
il vero nome in arte charlie davoli
intanto devo dire la più grande anomalia
in questo momento è il fatto che sia su
un palco perché fondamentalmente già
sentite la mia voce che trema
vuol dire che sono una persona molto
timida e non sono abituato a stare su un
palco e faccia lo sforzo della mente
l'immagine a questa sala vuota senza
nessuno dentro soltanto io quindi e
niente dunque ritornando a noi la
abbiamo introdotto all'uso di produzione
cerco definibili un attimo due parole
sono per metà un quasi fotografo e per
l'altra metà mancante un quasi in quasi
grafico il che significa che mi scusate
che mi diverto a come dire a catturare
quello che la realtà intorno a noi
attraverso gli strumenti fotografici
quindi attraverso uno scatto che
potrebbe essere apparentemente normale
apparentemente fanno dire anonimo
cerchio di come dire di catturare questa
parte anonima lavorarci su e cerca di
restituire un risultato è che sia
diverso che abbiamo una chiave di
lettura alle volte ironica scherzosa
giocosa perché siamo fondamentalmente
quello che mi accompagna sempre è il
voler divertirmi con con quello che è
scontato che io reputo scontato e quindi
cerco di dare una nuova chiave di
lettura renderla rendendola un po più
interessante che sono piccoli giochi di
prestigio fatti con photoshop
sostanzialmente quindi fotografia della
parte e photoshop dall'altra mi
completerò nell'insieme allora quindi
prima di levare al perché di questo
genere somma di interventi vado a fare
vorrei partire da fare una piccola
riflessione sul fatto una teoria un un
pensiero un pensiero condiviso un
pensiero elaborato da che cosa deriva
deriva necessariamente da una parte
precedente quindi ragionando ritroso un
pensiero nella teoria ha bisogno che una
precedente fase di studio sia stata sia
stata fatta quindi uno studio che è
praticamente si contorna anche di
verifiche esperimenti statistiche dati
raccolti condivisi e ripetibili ok e e
ancor prima cosa ancor più importante
dello studio esiste la parte di
osservazione quindi ogni fenomeno nel
momento in cui si si studia ha bisogno
che venga osservato precedentemente
quindi l'osservazione è molto importante
e dunque mi voglio soffermare un po
sull'osservazione l'osservazione
sappiamo bene che funziona anche in
maniera un essere umano può osservare
attraverso i propri sensi i sensi li
conosciamo tutti sono cinque
sappiamo bene come funzionano i sensi
dei piccoli recettori infiniti ricetto
nel corpo umano catturano steam
dell'esterno li convoglia non a sistema
neuronale va direttamente dritto al
cervello e il cervello quella macchina
finale che poi che poi elabora in tempo
reale cataloga le informazioni il
destino nei vari reparti di memoria
quindi tutto questo va come dire a
creare in un individuo una magazzino
informazioni un magazzino che può
diventare infinito non ha limite questo
magazzino e tutte queste informazioni
vengono elaborate dall individuo avrà
dunque che succede l'individuo perché
succede nel senso nel momento in cui
si ritrova confrontarsi con un'auto
individuo e io sto facendo come dire
alcuni immagina un po come questo l'uomo
primitivo nelle sue fasi e le prime fasi
di come di raccolta dati
all'improvviso deve necessariamente
anche cercare di condividerle
confrontarsi un altro gli video
altrettanto quest'altro individua ha
avuto la sua esperienza e dunque nel
momento in cui due individui e poi x 3x4
infinito questi individui
necessariamente devono sviluppare perché
nasce l'esigenza di sviluppare un modo
per comunicare
ok quindi la comunicazione avviene
tramite che cosa gli strumenti che sono
la fab rete un sistema numerico l'unità
di misura per cui nascono le convenzioni
queste convenzioni sono dei codici che
vengono trasmessi ripetuti e compresi
dai molti dai più poi al secondo poi
anche di quale parte della terra ci sono
con convinzioni diverse quindi tutte
queste convenzioni messe insieme cosa
creano creano lo scibile umano tutto ciò
che il sapere umano sapere umano si
compone poi di tanto di filosofia
letteratura musica
tutto ciò che l'essere umano in grado di
fant anche fantasticare detto questo noi
abbiamo però in questo sistema come dire
condiviso di convenzioni abbiamo un
problema nel senso abbiamo un piccolo
difetto questo difetto nasce da
mettiamola così un altrettanto difetto
dell'essere umano nel senso l'essere
umano nel momento in cui si trova di
fronte ad una convenzione imposta da un
sistema che in poi di seguire una
determinata convenzione diciamo la
subisce passivamente 15 un'assimilazione
passiva di tutto ciò che è una
convenzione strutturata ecco qui allora
la convenzione bypassarla è possibile
che succede
io trovo per esempio sin da quando ero
bambino interessante no
facciamo molta attenzione durante il
quotidiano durante conversazioni normali
dava molta attenzione a tutte le
manifestazioni un po anomala che ne so
errori di comunicazione un discorso
magari un discorso una parola meno usate
affinché di un'altra oppure una frase
disattenta no credo quelle piccole
stonature e può capitare queste piccole
stonature però per me però erano
interessanti e sempre più interessanti
nel senso tanto più questo per me è
diventato come dire una ricorrenza
quotidiana di oggi ancora gioco con
questo gioco col fatto che mi piace
osservare queste anomalie queste
anomalie in realtà cosa ci cosa ci ci
trasmettono trasmettono che cosa è una
piccola interruzione di tutto ciò che è
convenzionale nel senso convenzionale
ripetitivo e ossessionante l'abbiamo
accettato così com'è perché ci è stato
imposto un sistema più grande di noi e
quindi per me è tutto come dire una
ripetizione continua per me una stasi la
vivo come stati dunque questa piccola
anomalia genera un momento di terrore
ok un errore evita un errore da come di
rooney un impulso diverso quindi magari
il cervello nel momento in cui elabora
sempre sempre gli stessi impulsi
dall'esterno può ritrovare interessante
magari un errore all'improvviso no
perché finalmente c'è qualcosa diverso
bene quindi diciamo che io ho sempre
seguito questo errore
ho sempre cercato questa anomalia
io da da sempre ho ascoltato amato la
musica e nella musica ho scoperto
qualcosa di altrettanto interessante vi
capita mai di ascoltare un brano per la
prima volta
e durante l'ascolto è come se percepite
in anticipo qualcosa che si dovrà
verificare che ne so un certo punto la
canzone vi aspetta a ecco adesso
ritornello zac ritornello oppure adesso
so che ci sarà un cambio ritmico magari
la canzone diventerà più darkness o da
lenta ballad parte momento l'ampio di
intensità diciamo una percezione che voi
già preventivamente riuscite già ad
applicare
io questo lo trovo noioso nel senso ok
so chi mi aspetto mi aspetto ci sarà
quel cambio determinato accordo quel
successione di note cioè senso io non mi
sento soddisfatto e quindi sto in
perenne attesa che qualcosa di
imprevedibile accada ecco che cosa ha
scoperto
ho scoperto la dissonanza la dissonanza
è un'anomalia una ovviamente un'anomalia
studiata la dissonanza e quella figura
disarmonica in musica ad un certo punto
di un brano di scrittura interviene però
un intervallo che può variare a seconda
di quanto debba essere necessario questi
intervalli dissonanza che cosa crea
all'ascoltatore crea un momento di
movimento un momento di può sembrare
anche magari è stridente aspro no a
questo questa irruzione ma poi
immediatamente alla come dire alla
presenza di questa dissonanza
immediatamente serve poi un ritorno a
quello che era la stasi precedente la
stasi armonica precedente quindi si
ritorna nell'armonia nel concordare
insieme in un'armonia visto nell'insieme
allora quest'armonia dunque visto nell
insieme ovviamente poi da queste
informazioni certamente poi io traggo le
mie
idee le mie idee vengono manifestate
attraverso queste forme visive quindi
sono elementi si riproducono nelle mie
espressioni visive così che anche il
cinema influisce tantissimo nelle mie
come dire influenze
non so se riuscite a immaginare da
questa immagine
scusate il gioco di parole immagini
immaginare è un blocco un blocco un
parallelepipedo che galleggia in acqua è
un'immagine verosimile il reale però dal
cinema
tradotto questa lettura sicuramente
ricordate tutti quanti in un film io lo
nomino perché per ovvio motivo lo
conoscerete sicuramente tutti quanti
edizione uno spazio 2001 di kubrick e
kubrick a un certo punto nel film vabbè
non è stato pubblica scrivere la storia
ma ma nel film si vede all'improvviso
questo grande monolite apparire dal
nulla non si sa nulla perché non viene
spiegato nulla
la stessa presenza di questo monolite
che è lì nel silenzio in pieno silenzio
nero e inquietante e quindi è quella
dissonanza visiva che io subito o come
dire incamerato una dissonanza visiva
perché questa dissonanza creava disagio
con la presenza crea disagio e dunque
interessante per me tutto ciò che crea
un movimento per me interessante
altro esempio ave adesso no me lo sto
qui perché non l'ho trovato
non vi faccio vedere del secondo film di
cui vorrei fare l'esempio sicuramente
matrix può lasciare tutti quanti quindi
non a caso ho fatto questo esempio nelle
prime fasi del film ci sta il
protagonista che
nota una scena che si ripete due volte e
il gatto praticamente lui fa
probabilmente distrattamente non
riguarda allo stesso gatto nella stessa
identica scena fa lo stesso identico
passaggio nel film questo viene spiegato
come un errore un deja vu la scena il
déjà vu spiegato come un errore questo
errore dovuto ad una anomalia di
riscrittura nel sistema
ok ecco qua
anche qui continuiamo con kubrick allora
questo questa anomalia perché è
importante
generalmente quando subiamo passivamente
questi schemi convenzionali
purtroppo c come dire ci adagiamo siamo
confortati da tutto ciò che è
prevedibile nel senso non ci non ci
preoccupa sapere chi magari qualcosa che
ci possa destare un attimo di nodi di
movimento quindi noi siamo adagiati
passivamente su questo sistema ci
accompagna non c'è problema il mio ente
di stare un attimo così anche un po in
allerta
ok allora tutta questa dissonanza per me
diventa poi alla fine la matrice
fondamentale io in tutto questo sistema
di convenzioni trovo tutto quanto noioso
non riesco ad accettare questa questa
convenzione che praticamente per me è
noia
no tutte queste certamente ripetitive
che poi alla fine noi non riusciamo a
scorgere nulla al contrario prediligono
il momento del disagio nel disagio come
come questo mentre io sto qui magari
dopo un po così ma il disagio è quella
forma di agio no che è praticamente e
quell'interruzione quel momento in cui
si avvera un'interruzione qualcosa che
va interrompere qualcosa che si replica
si moltiplica warhol sosteneva che
questa dice che il consumismo la società
del consumismo praticamente raggiunge il
momento del loro in questa nostra
democrazia attuale la nostra democrazia
occidentale soprattutto perché lui ha
rappresentato attraverso attraverso il
suo immaginario quanto noi siamo
praticamente tutti uguali
amiamo gli stessi idoli guardiamo le
stesse cose e ascoltiamo le stesse cose
pensiamo alle stesse cose e mangiamo
tutti quanti la stessa minestra dunque
trovare la dissonanza per me quindi è
l'elemento come dire che collega tutto
quello che è fondamentalmente spiega
spiega ciò che voglio fare ciò che
vogliono rappresentare è una ricerca
continua di una dissonanza
allora vorrei andare un attimo avanti
scorro tra le immagini quindi saprete
che affermi fermo natti però io continuo
andare avanti fino a beccare ecco qua
questa è una ruota panoramica immersa in
un mondo di nuvole e dunque da qui
vogliamo dire che analizzando po quegli
sono le mie immagini perché io dico
chiamare un immagine può funziona più o
meno rispetto ad un'altra
può funzionare di più se io individuata
l'anomalia rs riesco ad ottenere un
risultato che sia gradevole armonico
nell'insieme così come ad esempio nella
musica ma che comunque riesca a
contenere una dissonanza una nomina
anomalie un errore un difetto non riesco
a contenere quindi la mia preoccupazione
restituire qualcosa che apparentemente
sia verosimile sia plausibile che possa
sembra davvero reale è tutto qui il
trucco il meccanismo in cui mi piacevano
immergermi e giocare in continuazione
dunque sta tutto qui rendere possibile
l'impossibile attraverso dissonanze
difetti prospettive ingannevoli giochi
giochi incastri e di qualsiasi natura e
ottenere un risultato gradevole perché
nell'armonia come la musica
l'effetto finale deve essere comunque
consonante e dunque andiamo avanti ad un
esempio
ecco qui questo ad esempio
diciamo che un'immagine che praticamente
ho anche un po di come dire un certo
affetto verso questa immagine
non so per quale motivo questa è
un'immagine composita nel senso ci sono
due frame esattamente due frame
sovrapposti insieme e sono individuabili
subito abbiamo la scena di una
metropolitana
ok uno scatto che io ho fatto a milano
l'altro frame e la livello dove si vede
la natura allora intel insieme vediamo
la scena
sicuramente reale sicuramente
impossibile ma resa così può essere
magari possibile ok
e la cosa sconcertante il fatto che gli
individui siano all'interno di questa
scena completamente assenti nel senso
poco attenti a ciò che gli succede
intorno
e questo è grave perché è ciò che
comporta il sistema il sistema ti rende
nella sua convenzione un essere privo di
qualsiasi forma di anche di
di interazione perché non sia crisi non
sia una forma di come dire di
autocritica e dunque si assiste
passivamente a qualsiasi cosa intorno a
noi
tutto ciò che è macroscopico poi
soprattutto diventa invisibile ai nostri
occhi e questa è veramente una scena da
emblematica abbiamo questi personaggi
che sono lì passivamente
in questo contesto impossibile ok quindi
una cosa impossibile dovrebbe dovrebbero
minima me sa come minimo essere
allucinati o comunque di resto uno stato
come dire di visibilio invece no sono
passivi
questo perché è così nel in questo
sistema ripetuto nella scena autentica
in effetti di attori sono davvero
disattenti sono davvero distratti sono
davvero assenti perché nella scena
metropolitana cosa abbiamo
abbiamo una scena in cui il racconto
della nostra vita moderna
la metropolitana simbolo di velocità
movimento dove viviamo la tecnologia
istantanea abbiamo la possibilità di
connettersi in tempo reale con tutto il
mondo
quindi l'immagine metropolitane
l'immagine della civiltà in movimento
una civiltà veloce iperveloce talmente
iperveloce che ci dimentichiamo anche
delle cose più importanti che sono anche
il vicino di casa al vicino di chi sta
seduto accanto a noi non ignoriamo
completamente e denota la nostra come
dire privazione di umanità perdiamo
sempre più umanità ci dimentichiamo di
essere degli umani ci dimentichiamo di
avere sentimenti ci dimentichiamo di
avere accortezza del nostro vicino ce lo
dimentichiamo
figuriamoci di fronte una scena così
esageratamente rho finta mentre la scena
della natura e una foto che ho fatto un
anno fa domani fare solo ricordo in un
viaggio dei miei soli di viaggi che
durante il viaggio in me piace comunque
documentare mano ai fini come dire di
avere una casa nuvole per la fotografia
di guardare nel tempo come ami diario il
mio di euro d'iva dei viaggi no scatto
sempre cosi che per me potrebbe essere
interessanti probabilmente in quel
momento non è interessante però quella
scena di natura per me era interessante
e ho trovato poi successivamente
l'incastro giusto questa scena di natura
fu fatta fu scattata a castelluccio
siamo in in un mese non sbaglio nella
scusate minoranza e castelluccio di
norcia è un paesaggio sebbene ha
martoriato da profonde cicatrici dovute
al cataclisma di tre anni fa che
praticamente ha distrutto innumerevoli
paesi innumerevoli città nonostante
questa cicatrice la natura comunque
prende possesso dei suoi propri spazi la
natura ritorna a riprendere possesso i
suoi propri spazi ed è come dire la
natura agisce anche in maniera
come dire non sta badare ad essere umano
va bene quindi ritorna prende tutto ciò
che il suo questo che ci fa capire che
noi esseri umani alla fine non siamo
proprietari di questo che abbiamo sotto
di noi dobbiamo capire che noi siamo dei
custodi
siamo soltanto dei custodi il nostro
compito custodire nel nostro breve
periodo
ciò che non ci appartiene con l'obbligo
morale di restituirlo al meglio
possibile ai successivi che verranno
dopo di noi
ok la natura fa il suo corso riprendo
tutto ciò che è suo
va bene anche in maniera drastica e
tragica l'evento tragico c'è ma
purtroppo la vita va avanti
allora ci abbiamo la sua conclusione
dello speech dicevamo abbiamo un po così
analizzato tratti di disumanità no
vediamo il secolo dove il progresso e
sfrenato
la tecnologia e iper performante dove il
mondo digitale pian piano sta
sostituendo il mondo reale
le nostre identità li stiamo boicottando
per bit informazioni numeriche informati
che viviamo il secolo del cemento che
praticamente vuole vuol sostituire anche
le foreste millenarie il secolo della
plastica che sta invadendo i fondali
marini il secolo del denaro che
praticamente governa le sorti del globo
bene l'essere umano sicuramente potrà
essere capace di erigere enormi
verticali di cemento di vetro di ferro
sempre più verso il cielo sempre più
imponenti però
risulta ofori di umanità ok sempre più
passivamente assorbito nella sua
ripetizione morante il sistema è sempre
più privo di spirito
allora le tecnologia ci sta assorbendo
tecnologia qual così positiva certo
innovazione tecnologia e lo sviluppo
l'andare avanti il progresso però ci
dimentichiamo in questa fase
disumanizzazione che è importante avere
anche lo spirito un animo allora
importante che ci sia armonia e non
soltanto dissonanza tecnologica rumore
tecnologico rumore informatico quindi ci
vuole anche un insieme globale visto di
armonia e nell'armonia esiste
l'equilibrio ciò che dissonante insieme
a ciò che armonico tecnologia e anima
tecnologia e spirito insieme diamo
viaggiare insieme io credo molto nelle
prossime generazioni nel prossimo
millennio dove praticamente abbiamo
stiamo esautorando questa ostentazione
del progresso tecnologico
credo ci sia c sera ci sarà e mi auguro
che ci sara anche presto un'inversione
tendenze dove la spiritualità torna ad
essere importante il nostro occidente il
nostro occidente si definisce come la
civiltà progredita ma a mio avviso se
parliamo in termini di spirituali
spiritualità l'occidente e il terzo
mondo dello spirito dell'animo quindi io
vi lascio con quest'ultima immagine un
gioco un gioco aereo
surreale verosimile non lo so però mi
auguro in questo gioco che tutti noi
continuiamo a giocare anche la ricerca
di una dissonanza una dissonanza che può
essere anche le ricerche di un gesto
anomalo ricerca no ma l'oggi purtroppo è
diventato anche la come dire essere
cortesi nei riguardi del tuo vicino di
sedia non si è cortesi ci si prima del
saluto è diventato anomalo salutare è
diventato anomalo essere gentile
diventato anomalo allora in questa
anomalia
cerchiamo di ricercarla a farla
diventare giocosa e di ritornare a
qualcosa che possa nutrire il nostro
animo e lo spirito per un non lo so un
futuro migliore non per noi ma spero per
altri futuri grazie a tutti
[Applauso]